it finally happened Donald Trump
indicted and arrested he's the first
ex-president charged with a crime or As
Trump put it he has been indicated
indicated with 34 felony counts of
falsifying business records in the first
degree now as we'll talk about later the
number of felony counts is not a good
proxy for the seriousness of the crimes
especially here where it looks like
everything relates to the same Nexus
effects but first things first this is
the first time in history that a former
president of the United States has been
indicted although it's worth remembering
that the justice system actually
frequently holds elected officials
accountable vice presidents have been
charged with breaking the law Governors
Congress people Mayors and all sorts of
other politicians have all gone to
prison for committing crimes because in
America no one is supposed to be above
the law of course if you live outside of
Illinois your odds get way better
nevertheless Trump posted that he was
shocked that he was treated like some
Regular Joe he posted heading to lower
Manhattan the courthouse seems so
surreal wow they are going to arrest me
can't believe this is happening in
America Maga though Trump did get a
little special treatment because he was
allowed to forego the usual perp walk
and mugshot which anyone else would have
had to go through but the timing of the
indictment caught most people by
surprise news sources had just reported
that the grand jury was going on Hiatus
until May without indicting Trump so
score one for the confidentiality of the
grand jury system but now that Trump has
been arrested reigned and released on
bond the indictment and statement of
facts are public so let's think like a
lawyer and break it all down now Donald
Trump has been indicted for 34 counts of
falsifying business records and during
our last video about the New York case
we discussed the possible facts that
would give rise to an indictment for
falsifying records every New York
business is required to keep certain
business records and New York penal law
section 175.10 makes it a crime to
delete alter or make a false entry in
the business records of an Enterprise
with the intent to defraud to get a
conviction for falsifying business
records the government must prove that
Trump either made or cause someone else
to make a false entry to his company's
business records and a defendant who
requests that someone else do the actual
work reporting a false business record
is just as criminally liable as if they
did it themselves now according to the
Manhattan DA's indictment and the
attendance statement of facts the D.A is
alleging the following facts the records
concern a catch and kill scheme with AMI
the parent company of the National
Enquirer the idea was that the National
Enquirer would help Trump win the
presidential election by finding
negative stories about him and then
buying the rights to those stories the
plan was for AMI to then conceal those
stories rather than publicizing them
according to the New York indictment the
scheme went from August of 2015 to
December of 2017. the first one was to
pay off a doorman who worked at Trump
Tower the man claimed to have a story
about Trump having a secret love child
and am I paid him thirty thousand
dollars to keep quiet the statement of
facts says quote am I purchased the
information from the doorman without
fully investigating his claims but Ami
CEO David pecker directed that the deal
take place because of his agreement with
Trump and Michael Cohen the party who
subsequently decided that they thought
the doorman was lying the second
incident involved Playboy Bunny Karen
McDougall who the statement of facts
refers to as woman number one am I
arranged to pay McDougall 150 000 in
exchange for the right to her story
about an alleged affair with Trump am I
told McDougall that she would get to
write articles for AMI Publications and
would be featured in cover stories about
her other exploits with famous men as we
discussed in our last video linked below
am I CEO David pecker had a conversation
with his lawyer about the scheme and
promptly backed out of the deal am I
entered into a non-prosecution agreement
with the New York D.A where it admitted
to unlawful conduct including making
false business records to conceal the
purpose of the 150 000 payment to
McDougall now that being said the
doorman and McDougall payments don't
seem to be part of this indictment
because they're outside of the five-year
statute of limitations and although
pecker and am I stopped participating
directly in exchange of money they
continued to broker deals for Trump
including facilitating the settlement of
the Stormy Daniels payment David pecker
allegedly told the grand jury that he
brokered an NDA between Daniels and
Cohen quote shortly after the axis
Hollywood tape became public the Ami
editor-in-chief Dylan Howard contacted
pecker about Stormy Daniels who elated
she had a sexual encounter with Trump
while he was married pecker told Howard
to notify Michael Cohen Dylan Howard
testified that he communicated with
Cohen about Daniels and also helped
Daniels find lawyer Keith Davidson and
according to the doj's filings against
Cohen Howard and pecker contacted Cohen
through an encrypted app to let him know
that Daniels was close to a deal with
the media Outlet to Spill the Beans
about her affair with Trump and the
National Enquirer had honchos then
negotiated the 130 000 settlement and
also confirmed the NDA with Davidson and
the statement of facts confirms that
Cohen and Ami admitted guilt in
connection with the payoffs of McDougall
and Daniels in the federal matters now
12 days before the general election in
2016 Cohen Drew Down 130 000 on a home
equity loan deposited into a shell
account and then paid Daniels off after
the election Trump started paying back
the initial 130 000 payment to Cohen but
he increased the amount to a total of
four hundred and twenty thousand dollars
now these checks apparently came from
the Donald J Trump revocable trust which
was created in New York to hold the
Trump organization nation's assets
during his presidency later checks came
from Trump's personal bank account in
total 11 checks were issued for phony
purpose Legal Services Trump signed nine
of those checks and according to the
indictment each check was processed by
the Trump organization and illegally
disguised as a payment for legal
services rendered pursuant to a
non-existent retainer agreement in total
34 false entries were made in New York
business records to conceal the initial
covert 130 000 payment and the
indictment concludes that the
participants in the scheme took steps
that mischaracterized these documents
for tax and election related purposes to
conceal the true nature of the
reimbursements and to hide the
reimbursements in total so why 34 counts
and what records did Trump allegedly
falsify will prosecutors charged each
false entry as a separate count for
example there are four counts related to
a single payment that was made to Cohen
on Valentine's Day in 2017 each count
related to a different document or
business record the first was related to
an invoice for that payment quote the
defendant made and caused a false entry
in the business records of an Enterprise
to it an invoice from Michael Cohen
dated February 14 2017 marked as a
record of the Donald J Trump revocable
trust and kept and maintained by the
Trump organization the second count
related to that payment was for the
making of a quote false entry in the
detailed general ledger for the Donald J
Trump replicable trust bearing foucher
number
842-457 and kept and maintained by the
Trump organization the third count and I
promise we are not going to go through
all 34 of these stupid things uh was
also for a false entry in the general
ledger the fourth count related to that
payment that was when Trump quote made
and caused a false entry the business
records of an Enterprise to whether
Donald J Trump revocable trust account
check and check stub dated February 14
2017 bearing check number zero zero zero
one three eight and kept it maintained
by the Trump organization so the
business records for that one payment
are the check and the check stub and an
invoice from Cohen a voucher of that
account and a voucher for another
account then the da basically uses the
same pattern for all of the other counts
it's basically one count for every check
or invoice now this isn't required but
it's also a totally normal way to charge
someone now there has been a ton of
breathless reporting about 34 felony
counts but
a prosecutor has discretion here they're
not required to list out every single
act that was part of a general criminal
scheme but by the same token it's also a
totally normal way of going about
writing an indictment and it's done all
the time
[Music]
so basically you can't conclude anything
from the fact that there's basically
three dozen different felony counts now
an additional wrinkle here is that for a
charge of falsifying a business record
to be a felony in New York state it has
to come with an additional requirement
of intent to defraud now under federal
law generally speaking intending to
defraud has a narrow construction but
New York state law interprets intent to
defraud much more broadly so that the
prosecutor can establish intent when the
defendant acts for the purpose of
frustrating the state's power to
Faithfully carry out its own law in
layman's terms that means that the
government doesn't need to prove that
Trump falsified business record for the
purpose of depriving someone of money or
property the government only has to show
that Trump did something to frustrate
the regulatory authorities of New York
and New York courts have found such
intent when a defendant did things like
making covert contributions to a
political campaign covering up an
alleged sexual assault misleading a
patient's relatives about the patient's
treatment and even operating a motor
vehicle without a license but this is
certainly a point of controversy and
it's likely a legal issue that will be
dealt with by the judge before the
factual questions ever reach a jury but
the statement of facts does try to
justify the charges the most significant
evidence that Trump knew what Cohen was
up to with the intent to defraud was a
conversation he had with Cohen about the
McDougall payments quote Cohen told
Trump he would open up a company for the
transfer of Karen mcdougall's account
and other information and stated that he
had spoken to Chief Financial Officer
for the Trump organization Alan
weiselberg about how to set the whole
thing up Trump asked so what do we got
to pay for this 150 and suggested paying
by cash when Cohen disagreed Trump then
mentioned payment by check after the
conversation Cohen created a shell
company called resolution Consultants
LLC on or about September 30th 22 16.
but the prosecutor will need to prove
that Trump knew about the Daniel's
payments too and that he agreed to
Cohen's payment scheme the statement of
facts alleges that Trump didn't want to
pay Daniels directly so he asked Cohen
to do it quote Trump did not want to
make the 130 000 payment himself and ask
Cohen and weisselberg to find a way to
make the payment after discussing
various payment options with weisselberg
Cohen agreed he would make the payment
before making the payment Cohen confirm
with Trump the Trump would pay him back
the saving facts alleges that Cohen made
the payment through a shell company with
Trump's blessing quote honor about
October 26 shortly after speaking with
the defendant on the phone Cohen opened
a bank account in Manhattan in the name
of essential Consultants LLC a new shell
company he had created to effectuate the
payment he then transferred 131 thousand
dollars from his personal home equity
line of credit into that account honor
about October 27th uh co-in wired 130
000 from his essential Consultants LLC
account in New York to lawyer B to
suppress Stormy Daniels account now the
statement of facts also goes into detail
about Trump organization CFO Alan
weisselberg agreeing to pay payback
Cohen more money than Cohen paid out so
the Cohen could characterize the payment
as income on his tax returns instead of
reimbursement and Cohen would be left
with 180 000 after paying approximately
fifty percent in income tax finally
weisselberg added an additional sixty
thousand dollars as a supplemental year
end bonus so the statement of facts
indicates that Trump knew about his
arrangement with Cohen quote Trump
weisselberg and Cohen then agreed that
Cohen would be paid 420 000 through 12
monthly payments of thirty five thousand
dollars over the course of 2017. each
month Cohen was to send an invoice to
Trump through Trump organization
employees falsely requesting payment for
thirty five thousand dollars for legal
services rendered in a given month of
2017 pursuant to a retainer agreement at
no point did Cohen have a retainer
agreement with Trump or the Trump
organization and the part about no
retainer agreement is key since Trump
May argue that he was simply paying
Cohen for Legal Services which is what
he indicated in the business records the
statement of facts also goes into some
detail about how each payment was
invoiced and made and I think this
detail is important once the election
was owed over and trumpet one he tried
to back out of paying Daniels at all
Quote Trump directed Cohen to delay
making a payment to Stormy Daniels as
long as possible he instructed Cohen
that if he could delay the payment until
after the election they could avoid
paying altogether because at that point
it would not matter if the story became
public this could end up being a key
allegation because it shows that Trump's
motivation was to influence the election
not to protect his family from
disclosure finally the statement of
facts alleges that Trump tried to
pressure Cohen to lie about their
Arrangement the pressure campaign
included Trump tweeting and Cohen to
stay strong and not flip and the D.A
also says that a different unnamed Trump
lawyer approached Cohen about
representing Cohen in his criminal case
offering to help him maintain a quote
back channel of communication to the
defendant in June of 2018 the lawyer
wrote to Cohen urging him not to Cave by
pleading guilty but Cohen did in fact
plead guilty in August of that same year
now as we talked about these are only
felonies if there is an attempt to
defraud and also an intent to commit
another crime or to conceal a commission
of a crime so what's the second crime in
this case well the indictment and
statement of facts don't say and New
York law doesn't require that the
prosecution identify the second offense
at the stage however you can bet that
there will be some motion practice to
force the government to issue a bill of
particulars to actually identify what
these crimes are however in a press
conference Alan Bragg identified three
general areas of law that he alleges
that Trump intended to break the scheme
violated New York election law which
makes it a crime to conspire to promote
a candidacy by unlawful means the 130
000 wire payment exceeded the federal
campaign contribution cap and the false
statements in Ami's books violated New
York law that is why Mr Trump made false
statements so Bragg mentions that the
130 000 payment to Stormy Daniels could
have violated the federal campaign
contribution caps uh because the hush
money payment was intended to benefit
the Trump campaign it could be
considered an in-kind contribution the
FEC limits individual donations to 3 300
per individual per candidate and in-kind
contributions are counted the same as a
cash donation so the 130 000 would be
way over that limit and as we covered
before there's a controversy about
whether a federal crime can be used as a
predicate for an underlying crime in New
York state and then there's also the
state conspiracy allegation New York
elections laws section 17-5-2 covers
conspiracy to promote or prevent an
election section 17-52 requires proof of
a conspiracy among two or more people to
promote the election of a particular
person to public office a
co-conspirators couldn't include Trump
Cohen Davidson Howard and pecker the
prosecution doesn't need to prove that
the defendant committed the second crime
just that the defendant intended to
commit it and there was also a
suggestion that the falsified record for
the purpose of tax fraud so we'll see
how this unfolds in the coming months
but it's also important to note that
even if the felony enhancement is
bounced by the judge or an appellate
court it's still likely that the
misdemeanor charges for falsification of
business records would remain and those
are still crimes there just wouldn't be
jail time associated with them now in
terms of defenses Trump is going to have
lots of them the Trump's criminal
defense will probably be different from
his public talking points for example
Trump and his Advocates have argued that
Prosecuting people for record-keeping
mistakes is proof that the whole Affair
is just a Witch Hunt since no one ever
goes to jail for falsifying records but
that's not accurate according to the New
York Times uh quote since Mr Bragg took
office in 2022 prosecutors have filed
117 felony counts of the charge against
29 individuals and companies so besides
the court of public opinion Trump also
has viable legal defenses to these
charges as well although the prosecutor
doesn't have to get a conviction on the
predicate offense the second crime might
be the best Avenue to attack the
record-keeping allegations I expect
Trump's lawyers to argue that the hush
money payments were not in-kind
contributions for campaign purposes uh
they were for the purposes of protecting
Trump's family rather than influencing
the election expect them to argue
Federal preemption that the federal laws
preempt state laws in this case or that
the federal laws can't be used as a
predicate for the state laws at all and
as we discussed in our previous video
about a potential Trump indictment it's
not at all clear whether all these
charges are within the statute of
limitations since the last allegedly
falsified record is from December 7th
2017 normally The Five-Year statute of
limitations would be up but during the
pandemic then New York Governor Andrew
Cuomo told the statute of limitations by
228 days for coveted related reasons so
this means that some of the charges are
probably still timely but those
extensions might not be enough to bring
in the other alleged acts in any case
Trump's best defense is to get these
charges dismissed on legal grounds
before it ever gets to a jury because
there isn't likely to be much
disagreement on the facts but there are
plenty of legal questions for the judge
to deal with long before trial now given
the unprecedented nature of these
proceedings there's going to be a ton of
trump videos in the future sorry or
you're welcome but there's so much stuff
that I can't release everything on
YouTube but thanks to the power of
today's sponsor nebula you can watch all
my videos ad free and early because all
my videos always go up on nebula first
well except for this one because we had
to write shoot and edit it in like 18
hours but other than that they all go up
on nebula first and now for limited time
you can get a lifetime pass to nebula
which is great because on nebula you get
access to exclusive videos like the Deep
dive we took on Trump's mental state for
the various crimes he's accused of and
the crimes that Steve Bannon was
pardoned for and my nebula classes which
include my entire course on how to sue
like a lawyer and my first full-length
documentary bad law words good those are
just a few of the tons of exclusive
videos that you get only on nebula so if
you sign up using my link that's on
screen right now or down in the
description you can get a lifetime
subscription to nebula it's good for
forever now obviously that's not going
to be for everyone so you can still get
an annual subscription for just thirty
dollars which is forty percent off the
regular price so sign up now and get a
lifetime pass or get 40 off by clicking
on the link below and get nebula for
only thirty dollars a year and after
that click on this link over here for
more legal eagle or I'll see you in
court